[Music]
[Applause]
reggie miller hall of famer turner's
sports nba analyst had the warriors
pelicans and now he's got the clippers
at the t wolves that'll be tomorrow
night 9 30 eastern on tnt
let's uh let's start with the news frank
vogel's future with the lakers
reportedly uh he will be fired today reg
uh your thoughts
uh first of all i'm not surprised but
let me just say this
it is absolutely
embarrassing
and bush league what the lakers have
done to frank vogel
uh i i'm and
look i know that coaches are always the
first in front of the fiery line the
coaches are always the first to go
but what they did to this man by
really attacking his character his
coaching resume
all behind closed doors
where there's other people
that should be held
at a higher standard for putting this
crappy roster together
like rob palinka
and jeannie buss
and even lebron james to a certain
degree
to throw russell westbrook
and frank vogel as they're the only
issues that was wrong with the lakers
this season
is
absolutely
embarrassing
it's embarrassing
and it's not right
it's not right again
coaches come and go and did frank vogel
have his flaws
sure
well sometimes his
uh fallen in love and out of favor with
certain players
yes i get it but let's remember one
thing
it's only 17 months ago that they or 18
months ago that they won a nba
championship with him at the helm
when they had either the first or second
best defensive team in the game
and all of a sudden he can't coach
he can't coach because of the roster he
did not put this roster together so
start talking about those people
that's what's embarrassing and it's just
not right to attack this man's character
it's not
and for him to face the firing squad of
the media right after that game
not knowing what his fate is and for
wojo to report that and wojo is just
doing his job which means he's getting
it sources from someone inside the
lakers organization there's only so many
people that could talk to wojo that
would have that kind of insight
and for him not to know that it's
embarrassing
is this a desirable job reg they've
missed the playoffs seven of the last
nine years
it's the lakers i mean that's like
saying
the yankees or the dodgers
of course it is or or the cowboys it's
very desirable but
there comes expectations they are
the world's team just like the yankees
just like the cowboys
and to a certain degree
of the boston red sox
yes desirable job becomes expectations
but also you don't control a lot
in that role it feels like and so you're
only going to be as successful as the
front office is going to make you
there's only so much you could do
they made these moves lebron cosigned
with this and then it's up to frank you
know the analogy i made is you got a bad
meal and you want to blame the waiter
not the chef and that's what i feel like
happened in los angeles
absolutely and
i guarantee you if
when frank vocal was probably approached
and says we're going this way with this
roster he probably looked at him crazy
like
there's no way there's absolutely no way
he did the best he he could with this
roster
i mean
but we knew this back in august when
they were putting this roster together
we all said that yeah oh this roster
would be unbelievable if it was 2010.
if it was 2010 this roster would be
balling
but it's not
it wasn't
but my point is
he is not the only one responsible
start calling wojo needs to start
calling out everyone who had a hand in
this
by name
not just frank vogel and not just
russell westbrook all right what's his
team now what do you do you're going to
bring in somebody i don't know if you
bring in mike brown but
what do you do with the roster what can
you do you got to [ __ ] up you first of
all you got to blow it up again they
have nine free agents just like they
blew it up a year ago there's nine free
agents russell westbrook is probably
going to opt in for that 47 million so
the bulk of your money is surrounded
around three guys
and we know who the three guys are so
now you've gotta
bring in
nine to ten new faces
that somewhat and on top of that find a
coach
find a coach who's gonna fit the
lifestyle
and fit the player compliment of lebron
anthony davis and probably russell
westbrook if he's not traded
would you trade entertain the idea of
trading anthony davis
yes i would
i absolutely would
he's got to show me he could stay
healthy
this will only work they will only be
successful if anthony davis plays
75 to 78 games a year
with lebron playing a year or two left
that's the only way the lakers going to
be successful if he can't stay healthy
which he hasn't over the last couple
years
absolutely they have no picks at least
you're gonna you gotta take
the oklahoma city thunder approach to
this
you've gotta start stockpiling draft
picks and assets
the lakers have zero assets other than
anthony davis and lebron james which i
know lebron's not going anywhere
but it should cross someone's mind
possibly
what could you get from you might just
have to blow the whole thing up
i would be bad for a while get picks
and then hope you get lucky
during the draft and find a generational
player
but you've got to start thinking big
picture
why is it that we it felt like people
the with the lakers said hey we got all
these injuries and then i started
looking at the injuries here and
you know
let's look at the golden state warriors
steph curry played thank you thank you
theodore thank you stop using that
anthony davis think of other teams that
are in the same position steph curry
played 64 games lebron played 56.
draymond green played 41 a.d played 40.
clay played 31 russ played 78
and the warriors still won over 50 games
that's what i mean
that excuse doesn't work
it doesn't work because of the model you
just said about oklahoma city it doesn't
work for the brooklyn nets who at kd was
out kyrie played half the games
james harden didn't want to be there
half the time and they traded him
they're in the play-in and probably will
be in the playoffs what about
philadelphia with the ben simmons saga
you think uh
before james harden get there
you know everything was on embiid you
know they're in the top four
everyone goes through injuries every
team went through a covet period
stop using that excuse lakers
stop it we're talking to reggie miller
the hall of famer turner sports nba
analyst i saw where there's a chance ben
simmons might be able to play with the
nets in the playoffs
how
man that is that is a delicate situation
to try to put him in it you know now
you're in the playoffs here i mean what
do you think about trying to incorporate
him into the lineup
look if anyone probably could do it
would be steve nash you're right about
it being a delicate situation because
you don't want to break
up team
chemistry but it's a guy who can help
you
the thing about why i think it could
work is because you're not
bringing him in to score the basketball
you have enough of that in kyrie and kd
what you're bringing him in to do
is do what bruce brown does
but in a 610 body
that means pick and roll
get into the middle of the paint and do
those little teardrops or kick it out to
the rest of the shooters like curry or
kyrie or find kd
so you're asking him to do the little
things and be great defensively which we
know he can do you're not asking him to
come in and score 20 points a game and
you're not asking him to play major
minutes if he could give you 15
18 maybe 20 minutes
absolutely so that's why i think it
could work
but a lot is going to depend on his
health
going forward i don't see him playing in
this play-in game but
i could see him in the first round at
some point if he's healthy
uh the best matchup
of the play in games is which one
in the playing games is i i really truly
believe the one we're calling uh tuesday
night
los angeles clippers and the minnesota
timberwolves
it seems like the clippers they've been
treading water all season long injuries
paul george missed 50 games he comes
back with what two weeks left in the
season
norman powell is back for them
and
coach liu
he always finds a way to get the most
out of his team and you know you're
talking about the lakers and injuries
they weren't without kawhi and pg all
these all these games and they they're
in the playing situation lakers your
costs down rivals yep so
look i i think that's the best playing
matchup i'm so excited because
people they really haven't seen
minnesota play this is
coach finch has these young guys ready
to run through a wall
and their talkative leader patrick
beverly who has
his former team in the clippers is
non-stop jabbering it's going to be a
fantastic matchup
between those two teams
should the suns be the favorites
they should be the favorites
on
they should get to the western
conference i do believe they will
you don't win
64 65 games on a fluke they've been the
most consistent team
they're well coached they have two
absolute
killers in crunch time if the game is
closed and chris paul and devin booker
they've got uh defense on the wings in
my opinion the defensive player of the
year mikhail bridges they've got a man
in the middle who can stretch the floor
block shots rebounds in ayton
they are the best team
in basketball um but it's the time to go
out and show it i i think they're still
a little
ticked off about losing being up 2-0 in
the finals versus milwaukee and losing
four straight
um this kind of reminds me of the year
when san antonio
should have beat miami in the finals
when ray allen hit the tying three yeah
and they want they go on to lose that
series in the finals but san antonio
comes back the next year and wins it
it it kind of reminds me a little bit of
that for phoenix they should have won
last season they didn't they're ticked
off and they come back even better
and they end up winning the championship
i could very well see that
and then in the east you like the bucks
so are we looking at a repeat of uh
buck's sons
i do i i i really do i i how about if
not the bucks then who
if it's not the bucks
i i like to go with consistency and
defense
and
boston
no i could see i could see miami okay
i can see miami just because they're
tough enough they got championship
experience in the head coach
at eric spoelstra
tucker is one year removed from winning
it in milwaukee
and i know a lot of times you don't know
what you're going to get from jimmy
butler but what you will get is heart
and hustle
and i think bam out of bio doesn't get
enough credit for what he does at both
ends of the floor
i could see miami if it's not milwaukee
i could see miami representing the east
what is it about jimmy butler that's a
mystery reg
i think he's a throwback to the 80s and
90s type players where
he holds his teammates as well as we saw
in that video coaches accountable he
gets it
gets into it with his teammates and
i respect him i love him i love his fire
i always have
i think his heart is always in the right
place there's
to me i think there's always better
times for him to display that as opposed
to
on the court with millions watching in
today's age with cameras everywhere
but i always think his heart is always
in the right place because at the end of
the day all he wants to do is win yeah
i i saw where kyrie was disappointed
that uh he was not on the
75 greatest players of all time list and
uh i think he referred to conspiracy
theorist
kind of uh you know that's the reason
why he's not on the top 75.
um talent-wise he should be
but he was never first-team all-pro
he did hit one big shot
but um
is is should kyrie be on the top 75
players of all time and why isn't he
you can make a case for a lot of people
dwight howard
vince carter tracy mcgrady and obviously
kyrie
there's a lot of players
alex english
so
everyone has a
gripe and i understand where he's coming
from
and as a player you should feel that
right he should feel that
and you're right about the talent wise
talent wise absolutely
um but he's been he's been injured he's
been hurt
a lot
uh i know he has a championship to his
name and the reason why they have that
championship is because of that big shot
he made
but
everyone has a gripe who's on the
outside looking in and
rightfully so they should be you should
feel like you're one of the top 75
players in the world
and he's i think that it's um
talent wise he's as good a ball handlers
i've ever seen
um
i just don't know if he's a great player
all the time i think he's a fascinating
player i just
i i can't count on him and then when he
wanted to have his own team in cleveland
lebron came in he did hit the big shot
then he wanted to have his own team he
went to boston that didn't work out well
then he goes to brooklyn and decides uh
katie i'm not going to be playing home
games with you so i
i think he's
he's he's definitely interesting
uh but i i don't know if he's a top 75
player talent yes player no
and i think all those things that you
just outlined probably factored into
whoever was doing the voting for this 75
team right i'm sure they laid all that
out and
went through the pros and cons
but
let me be clear here uncle drew in terms
of talent
ball handling
shot making
and
artistry he's box office wait were you
in the van with him when he got traded
when you guys were shooting that movie
yeah
it was it was it was shaq myself
c webb
and kyrie and we're getting ready to do
our van scene
and we all had our phones underneath
like one of the pillows in there
and they all went off at the same time
and we all looked at it
and then we all looked at him
he just started shaking his head
he's like okay well i guess i'm going to
boston and we were like well okay let's
do this
yeah yes we were
is there a sequel
god i hope so that was fun to make
it was fun it looked like you guys had a
lot of fun
but i haven't heard anything about a
sequel
well maybe it was fun to make but one
thing i will not miss is five hours of
makeup every single day that i will not
be because what you normally have on a
normal day is four hours of makeup right
well normally for games it's about three
and a half when i'm in the chair ready
to call games three and a half get it
right all right reg will be on the call
the clippers and the timberwolves any
chance kawhi leonard plays if the
clippers advance
i think he possibly could come back but
they would have to advance in my opinion
to the conference final okay if we
if we want to see kauai and and zion
you're there in new orleans is there any
possibility if the pelicans happen to
advance that zion will play
his step dad says he wants to see him
play this season well this season for
them
they have a game wednesday versus the
spurs
i don't see it but if they get into the
first round i would not be surprised
all right
make it safe travels great to talk to
you we'll talk to you next week
appreciate it theodore love you danette
that's uh reggie aloo wishes miller